Hello and welcome back to the third part of our forest building exercise.
And in this we're going to be adding some rocks to our forest.
Now to do this, I actually want to do a very similar thing to what we've done with our trees.
So what I'm going to do is I'm going to move my get landscape data down here a little bit.
And I'm going to grab all of this and I'm going to push C
and I'm going to call this... I'm going to call this rocks.
I'm going to duplicate this. So I'm going to left-hand click, select the whole thing,
press CTRL-C and CTRL-V to grab another one below, plug that into the landscape data.
And I'm going to change this to be called trees and bushes.
Trees and bushes. So on my comments, I will change it to be, double click,
trees and bushes, change the color to green, and I'm going to work on my old rocks up here.
So the first thing that I'm going to do is I am going to... I'm going to come into our
transform points. I'm going to change this around a little bit. I will, rather than making it 360 on
just one, I'm going to make this 360 on all three axes. That's because our rock is enclosed.
So theoretically we can place in any angle and it will look okay.
Okay, I'm also going to drag this further down into the ground because my intention
with these rocks is they're going to be sticking out of the ground.
I'm going to go between minus 100 and minus 200. The rotation is fine.
And the size. So what I'm going to do is I'm going to make the minimum
1 and the maximum 15. So all rocks can get quite large.
Now we also need to change our mesh that we're spawning.
So under the static mesh spawner, I'm going to remove one of the entries.
I only have one rock. And for my static mesh, I'm going to select,
yeah, you guessed it, my rock. Okay, so let's have a look at how this looks now.
Ta-da! It's not the ideal mesh. This is actually quite a small rock that we're scaling up.
But you can see that we now have a bunch of rocks sticking out of the landscape.
Well, this brings up a number of problems. The first one being that the rocks overlap with
themselves, as you can see here, and the rocks overlap with the trees and the bushes.
So I'm going to try and fix those and we're going to try and make it so that our rocks
are at least not overlapping with anything. We're going to do that by manipulating the points.
So let's jump back into here. And the first thing that I'm going to want to do is I'm
going to sort out the problem with them overlapping themselves.
And let's visualize this to start with. So I'm going to push E on the static mesh
spawner so we don't get our rocks. I'm also going to push E here so we don't have
to worry about the trees for the time being. And I'm going to push D on our transform point
so we can see what the points look like. And you can now see that what we've got is
we've got a whole load of jumbled points all on top of each other.
So we can see why we're getting a bunch of overlap at this point.
So in order to fix this, I'm going to hold down ALT to prevent the duplication problem.
Drag out. I'm going to search for self-pruning. I'm going to plug this back into the static
mesh and turn the D on the self-pruning. Now we have a couple of settings.
So at the moment you can see that our settings are large to small
and a similar radius factor is 0.25. So let's have a look at what that's done.
Bang! We now have much fewer rocks. And if I was to convert that and go small to large,
you can see that the effect now is we'd have smaller rocks all over the place.
So it would get rid of the largest ones first, but I am happy with large to small.
OK, so that looks quite good to me. However, as you can see here,
it's actually pruned quite a lot and there's big distances sort of between these.
The distances are going to get even bigger when I'm going to turn back on the enable
mesh spawner. And you can see that we have we can't quite see it yet.
And the pivot's slightly off. But if I come in to wireframe mode,
you can see that our bounding boxes are considerably larger than our rocks. And so
we're doing the pruning based on these point boxes. However, it does not match up
to our actual meshes. So let's fix that because that's going to allow us to have
a bit more accuracy on this whole thing. So what I'm going to do, the first thing is
I'm going to search for my rock. I'm going to double click and open this up.
And as you can see on this, the approximate size of the rock is 100 by 81 by 48.
So let's say 180, 50. Now, our surface sampler is 50 by 50 by 50.
However, that's going to be doubled. So that would be 100, 100, 100.
Where this is 180, 50 and 50. So what I'm going to do is change that to
I'll give this 50. So it's 80, isn't it? So we need 40. And finally, we need about 25.
So now, if we have a look at our bricks, you can see that these are a lot closer to
where the actual bricks are. It's actually still sticking out a little bit from that.
I could fix that just by editing the pivot slightly. So I'll show you how to do that.
I'm going to come out of wireframe, drag my rock into the world and focus on it.
You can see the pivot is a little bit towards the center.
Now, the easiest way to change the pivot is to come over into modeling mode.
And under X form, we have the bake transform edit pivot.
And if I just drag that pivot a bit forward, I'm going to go back one, I think.
Go accept. And that should save the pivot to the mesh. Delete that down.
Now, it still doesn't look perfect. That's a little bit better.
But you can see, you can play around with that and you can turn off snacking
in order to get the mesh. But if we look at the wireframe here, you can see it's considerably
closer. And this means that the pruning is going to be more accurate because our
actual models are closer to our boxes that we're using to calculate the pruning.
Okay. So that is my rock I've saved. And our PCG graph.
So I'm going to come out of wireframe mode so we can see what we're working with.
And I'll turn off the self-pruning.
And we'll look, we have a number of rocks on our landscape.
Okay. Nice. I'm happy with that. And let's look at our next problem.
So our next problem is our trees. If we bring our trees back in one second and look here,
it's not going to be terribly prominent, but you can see, I can't even spot it. Here you go.
So our tree is sticking out of our rock.
So let's look at fixing that. I'll keep my mouse there so we can see when it's fixed.
I'm going to come back into my PCG graph.
I am going to drag this across and my static mesh spawner. Hold down alt to disconnect.
I'm going to drag out and add in a difference mode and plug that into the output.
I need to do a conversion back to points. So I need to fit that in.
So what we've got is a difference node and we need to, we're going to plug the output of
the self-pruning into this difference node. Now with the difference node, you can see that
we've got a couple of options here. Density function minimum. I'm going to change the density
function to binary. So you either want something to be removed or not removed.
Okay. Now let's have a look at the wealth and bang, a whole load of trees are gone because
they overlap with the rocks. So that's great. So now our trees are growing,
not directly out of rocks. Okay. So that gives us a slightly more put together forest.
So thank you for listening to this far. In the next one,
we're going to be adding in some grass and flowers.